[Musique]
comment chanter chanteuse je n'y avais
vraiment jamais pensé que j'avais je
vais voulu être danseuse mais chanter
c'est une autre affaire non pas que je
chante faux mais enfin je chante comme
comme tout le monde et dix bombes pour
chanter il faudrait qu'on me voit des
idées de chansons enfin quelle chanson
puis elle m'a réussi cette idée allez
allons trouver certes on veut lui
demander conseil et marc cria toujours
étourdi comme élève comme à l'accoutumée
ou quelle bonne idée
sans s'en rendre absolument content que
on avait huit jours pas plus pour
arriver à faire ce qu'on avait à faire
l'ours arbres nous inviter à dîner avec
son ami jacques l'or en bosses tu es
avec anne-marie comme j'aime feeling
tennis est à montmartre je me rappelle
c'était c'était un soir très doux la fin
du printemps et nous rend travaux à pied
de montmartre jusqu'à saint germain des
prés comme ça parmi les rues endormi je
marchais à côté de ça après quand même
dans ma tête a eu cette pensée 2 le
travail ce boeuf sur le toit
j'étais inquiète et je le dis je
voudrais chanter avec la logique la plus
parfaite il me regarde et me va chanter
chanter trouve quoi et je lui ai exposé
mes goûts je lui ai expliqué ce que
j'avais envie de chanter je le dis que
les chansons que les autres chantaient
ne m'intéressait pas que je ne voulais
pas mal et chanter à ce moment là
c'était en c'était l'époque des serena
elle enfin la seule chanson que j'aime
et à ce moment là c'était les feuilles
mortes
je lui explique tout ça on dit bon
écoute et très bien revenez demain matin
là vers la maison 9 heures 9 heures pour
moi c'était ce dès l'aube
je n'ai pas très bien je serai demain
matin et vers le lendemain à 9 heures
j'étais là je sonne à la porte
il aime ouvrir ce mets derrière son
bureau est sur le bureau il avait toute
une pile de livres dans lesquels ils
avaient très soigneusement insérer des
petits signé le papier blanc entre
certaines pages il y avait à peu près
neuf livres et me dit bon prenez les
livres surtout rapporté les mois je prie
les livres je les lui et parmi ces
livres l'invs et 1 de raymond queneau
dans lequel était un poème
si tu t'imagines
il y avait un lafforgue dans lequel je
prie l'éternel féminin et il y avait
aussi un très joli poème et même du
claudel et ça je n'ai pas pris j'avais
un très joli poème de cocteau qui
s'appelait à palma de majorque tout le
monde est heureux on mange dans la rue
dès sorbet au citron
je vais pas chanter non plus mais c'est
très joli et puis voilà et le lendemain
je revins avec tous mes livres que je
rapportais soigneusement le poser sur le
bureau je fis par un sartre de mon choix
elle sourit ça il avait l'air content il
est bon très bien je suis content je
suis content de votre choix mais puisque
c'est comme ça je vous faire un cadeau
certain monsieur qui qui fait beaucoup
de cadeaux tellement tellement qu'il est
totalement dépossédés et le banc
probable c'était qu'est ce que c'est
mieux c'est une chanson que j'écris pour
huis clos où elle s'appelle la rue du
blanc manteau ce choix que je veux le
faire avec sartre ne comportait que des
poèmes donc il n'y avait pas de musique
et fallait les mettre en musique
alors je posais la question à sartre et
elle me dit écoute et puisque vous aimez
les feuilles mortes pas aller voir kosma
facile à dire plus difficile à faire
d'abord je ne savais pas où il habitait
et puis c'est et am2 un peu gênant et 10
pour écouter l'égide ma part on peut pas
téléphoner à gauche moi parce qu'il
n'avait pas le téléphone ils habitaient
dans deux chambres de bonnes
l'université je me rappelle cette
première visite très précisément il fait
très chaud et j'arrive avec un gros
bouquet de pois de senteur bien serré
comme ça je frappe à la porte elle
mariée derrière moi la porte s'ouvre
madame cosma et là elle est en train de
copier de la musique on nous fait
asseoir on nous offre un verre de
banyuls et par les fenêtres ouvertes il
ya les abeilles qui viennent équivalent
au tour de verre et puis je donne mes
textes à caspar
il aime cette ut imagine l après midi
même et leur fait la musique
moi je suis là
maintenant il va lui falloir chanter
alors d'un doigt ne joue les mélodies
note après note je l'entends
je ne peux pas la chanter parce que ma
gorge elle nous est totalement serré je
ne peux rien faire elle mariella
toujours derrière le surveille excepté
deux fois pointue que ça comme une
aiguille rouille elle chante et moi j'ai
une voix très grave très pas ce jeu
commence à faire puis
et puis tout d'un coup le miracle s'est
produit pour moi il ya eu le miracle
voilà ça y est je m'envole je me marre
jeantet et depuis j'ai toujours chanté
[Musique]